the long intermission is over for cirque
du soleil
the curtain is finally rising on missier
which is the first
cirque show on the las vegas strip since
the pandemic started
the performers are understandably
excited to get back to work
on 8 news now good day john langler
talked with cirque du soleil president
and ceo daniel lamar
daniel thank you for joining us this
morning how are you i'm
good i'm good i'm so excited that
finally our shows are coming back
it's a it's a great week for us so
mister at treasure island opens today i
know there was a test show i think it
was friday night
uh how did that go first and foremost
and just how excited are you
to finally be back on stage the good
news is our artists are in
better shape than we expected they're
great they're pumped they're ready to go
the dress rehearsal went very very well
the quality of mystere is there
the people are going to find the same
style
that they saw you know many months ago
and
uh we're very excited about it it's the
rebound it's the relaunch of cert du
soleil
in las vegas which as you know is so so
important to us
so important mystere was my first circ
show i've seen oh i've seen
love uh talk about the other shows up
and down the las vegas strip when
might we see them finally get back on
stage as well
yeah we have a big event on july 1st to
the for the reopening of
o and then we're uh reopening uh michael
jackson uh one
on august 18 and then the week after
we're
uh reopening all so we will have
all of our showbot car open uh by
mid-august
and then we're looking to all open
sometime
in the fall which means that all our
shows are going to be back
and vegas as you know represents so much
of our company that having all those
show open
really means that the intermission is
over and
maybe we can talk about that briefly uh
you know the pandemic
hurt everybody up and down the las vegas
strip all across the valley the
entertainment industry
uh cirque du soleil there were some
financial problems
just at the cusp of the pandemic
bankruptcies and so forth where do
things stand right now in terms of a
firm footing for the entertainment
in las vegas from a cirque point of view
moving forward and recovering from the
pandemic
yeah first of all the good news is that
we have new investors new shareholders
that have
injected over 375 million dollars
to keep the company running which
ensure the future of the organization
now that our shows are back obviously
we are in even a healthier uh financial
situation
so our cast and crew our employees now
can feel very secure that the sun
of sergio soleil is rising and is rising
forever
and this is great great news for all our
cast and crew that deserve
to have the support of our shareholder
to have the support of us
and i'm so so happy now to report that
serge du soleil is
in las vegas forever and i want to just
quickly go back to friday night what was
it like
at treasure island with from astaire for
that first time back
on stage a couple of my friends were
there they said it was an emotional
event it's a great show of course but
just for you to see it actually on stage
again uh must have been quite the
experience
a lot of emotion i can tell you i've
seen that rehearsal i also saw a
rehearsal of oh
and for me that was for the first time
in 18 months
a visualization that the show is back
that our artists are back
because at the end of the day what count
is our cast and crew where a bunch of
creators
and artists and to see them back in
stage
was not only relief but i was a great
celebration
and yes i can tell you there was a lot
of emotion
for all of us oh that's wonderful to see
well the only cirque show that has not
announced a return date yet is ca
that is expected to return sometime in
the fall